hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be a bonus Game of Thrones
video about what they might do after
season 7 they just made a whole bunch of
comments about going beyond 10 years
that doesn't necessarily mean that will
get Game of Thrones season 10 so this
will be a breakdown of the storylines
they could do as well as like when
george RR martin had to say about it so
if you didn't see it there was an
interview with the president of HBO
programming the person who's responsible
for buying new shows he said we would
love to go beyond 10 years with Game of
Thrones as of right now the actors are
only confirmed through season six like
there's only a contract with HBO through
season six there have been a lot of HBO
shows that have run for a long time
seven seems like the magic number
even for unsuccessful series so I don't
think that it's going to be a problem
getting to season 7 there's just there's
too much material to wrap it up in six
seasons they're already skipping so much
stuff what's probably going to end up
happening is is the producers Dan and
Dave as well as the actors will not want
to go beyond season seven so here's a
breakdown of like likely outcomes in
this situation where you have like a
whole bunch of material but a limited
amount of time to get it out so you know
most likely what's going to happen is
we'll get season seven and they'll wrap
the series up you know for the most part
and have to cut out a whole bunch of
stuff like they'll cut out a lot of
stuff moving down the list a little bit
season eight slightly less likely I
would put it like 60% chance that
they'll do a season eight to wrap things
up as for the odds of a movie george RR
martin himself said that you know yes
it'd be great to do a movie but the
president of HBO said that he wasn't
really hot on the idea just because
HBO's driven by television subscribers
even if they aired the movie on HBO
you'd be paying a full month's
subscription fee for two hours of
programming out of the four weeks of
programming you would normally get so
just as a cost-benefit analysis that the
executives at HBO feels like there's
better value in not doing a movie that
doesn't mean they won't ever do
theatrical stuff again regardless of
what happens with the show they'll
probably do IMAX screenings again I
think they were really successful
financially people really liked them but
what'll probably happen is is the wait
till after the episodes air
TV to do that they're not going to throw
subscribers under the bus subscribers or
their first priority suicide step what
is the alternative starting a spinoff
that's probably what's going to end up
happening will get like seven series of
the main show and then they'll do a
prequel series as a spinoff
so we will get like 10 15 years of Game
of Thrones or however many the spin-off
runs for but the other material beyond
season seven will not be part of a Song
of Ice and Fire it'll be like prequel
stuff right now that's what The Walking
Dead is doing most popular TV show in
the world
Walking Dead is like the only show
that's more popular than Game of Thrones
Robert Kirkman and AMC want more Walking
Dead like they make a ton of money on it
so they want as much as possible
but there's only so much they can do
with the main cast at a certain point
they'll just they'll run out of stories
to tell people just get tired the actors
will want to move on and do other
projects just like the Game of Thrones
actors or they'll become too expensive
to pay usually usually the big problem
beyond Season seven is that you have to
give the actors like astronomical raises
especially on really successful TV
series when you do a spinoff you
completely bypass that problem you can
bring in total unknowns you already have
brand awareness so it costs way less
it's way easier to produce and you
already have the built-in audience from
the main show it's really an
embarrassment of riches in terms of like
a Song of Ice and Fire prequel material
for them to pick from but I feel like
there are two really likely candidates
there's the tales of Dunkin egg and then
there's the Targaryen Civil War of the
two of those I feel like the most likely
candidate is just the tales of Dunkin
egg just because Martin spent a lot more
time developing that storyline and he
said that beyond the three novellas that
he's done he will write new material but
right now he's working on winds of
winter as everyone is yelling at him so
it's probably gonna be a long time
before there's new Dunkin egg stuff the
really funny thing about canonical
material outside of A Song of Ice and
Fire is that like every time George R
Martin does a new public appearance he
talks about doing other storylines
that don't have to do with the main
novels it's so funny so he's always
announcing new material he'll be writing
new stories until he's dead in the grave
it'll be a tolkien's situation where his
heirs will have to finish his material
based on notes that he's left like
there's just way too much stuff for him
to finish in his lifetime I know
something you're asking why don't they
do a seer
about ancient Valyria why don't they do
a series about Aegon's conquest I think
the answer is is that some stuff just
works better in flashback when you just
get like brief looks at it those are two
really good examples of storylines that
will require heavy digital effects
because you have lots of dragons lots of
really big battles and lots of big
ecological destruction a la doom of
Valyria even if you don't do the doom of
Valyria there were so many dragons you
couldn't throw a stone without hitting a
dragon in ancient Valyria think about
how much they would have to spend on
digital effects so dunk an egg just a
better choice just wait way less special
effects required much easier to produce
some of you guys are probably asking
what the hell is duncan egg you probably
heard the names before you probably
heard them referred to but you may not
have read the short stories or the
novellas so dunk refers to sir dumped in
the tall that's this guy right here and
egg refers to Aegon Targaryen v the
individual novels that their stories are
in are out of print right now but this
fall in october george RR martin is
collecting a new edition with some new
artwork just like he did with world of
Ice and Fire last year the difference is
is that the tales of duncan egg is all
George RR Martin's writings world of Ice
and Fire
I know a lot of people were upset
because it was just a collaboration he
only wrote part of it it was still a fun
book but for those that just want to
read stuff the George R Martin has wrote
tales of duncan egg is much better their
adventures mostly covered this period of
time before Aegon had become the king
and sir duncan had become part of his
Kingsguard here's a quick breakdown on
how that storyline gets started so just
careful for spoilers if you don't want
to know anything about duncan egg the
series picks up when duncan is only a
squire hoping to become a knight the
night that he's serving under is
nicknamed the hedge Knight he dies while
he and dunk are on their way to a
tournament in Ashford Duncan seizes the
opportunity to become a knight much
faster normally it takes a long time to
become a knight so he takes the hedge
Knights armor and gives himself the name
Sir Duncan the tall saying that the
hedge Knight knighted him right before
he died the problem when he gets to the
tournament at Ashford is that no one
believes him nobody remembers the hedge
Knight except for one of the Targaryen
princes Prince Baylor
he agrees to let sir Duncan fight in the
tournament so he's bluffing his way into
the tournament and he's kind of on shaky
ground
he stays it in in and it just so happens
that a young Targaryen Prince named egg
nicknamed egg is staying there so egg or
egg on the fifth everyone to think about
him is like so far down the line of
succession that he doesn't even care
about becoming King he wants to become a
knight so that he can become a
Kingsguard someday most of his family
thinks this is blasphemous and he has
several siblings he has an older brother
that's kind of like Joffrey total
[ __ ] way further up the line of
succession than him even his father
Prince maker the first is still a prince
you have to remember that like at this
time in history they're just lousy with
Targaryen their Targaryen everywhere
like each one of them has like a billion
kids because egg is staying at the same
Inn as Sir Duncan he seizes the
opportunity to try and become Sir
Duncan's squire he bakes him he's like
please let me be your Squire but he
doesn't tell him that he's a Targaryen
Prince he just lies about his identity
it says his name's egg duncan agrees but
then later in this kind of misguided act
of chivalry duncan ends up in a trial by
combat with eggs older brother aerion
Targaryen here's where things get really
cool so aryan challenges dunk to a trial
by combat
but not just any trial by combat not
like Oberyn Martell vs. the mountain he
challenges them to a trial by seven
trial by seven is a seven on seven trial
by combat where seven knights face seven
other knights all seated on horseback
you can pick whatever weapon you want to
use usually its Lance's though because
you're on horseback dunk is able to win
but in a series of unfortunate events a
whole bunch of really important people
died including bail or Targaryen eggs
uncle eggs father Prince maker says that
you know you know because he won he
could become part of his personal guard
Dunc refuses says i just want to be a
knight and eggs father agrees to let
duncan Squire egg who at this time had
revealed himself as Aegon the fifth but
he's still way down in the line of
succession so he thinks he has zero
chance of becoming King the rest of
these three stories just go on to tell
their adventures after that you know
deal with a couple really big important
events in Westeros so there's a lot of
really big stuff happening outside of
what's going on with Duncan egg so it's
pretty exciting it's a really good story
there's like there's just enough battles
for them to do some really cool action
set-pieces it's like the Song of Ice and
Fire if it were told from the
perspective of Brienne or Jaime
Lannister so you get a much deeper dive
into the line of succession inside the
Targaryen 's as well as what knighthood
is like it's just a lot of fun I know I
said it's a little less likely that they
might do dance of the Dragons or you
know the the Targaryen Civil War the
reason that that would be really cool to
do is because it gives you a much deeper
dive into dragon lore like what is
involved in writing dragons how does
that work that series of short stories
really explores that so it's way more
dragon heavy and it's within about two
hundred years of the main series so it's
not super far removed as opposed to like
ancient Valyria here's my big question
for you guys if they do a prequel series
what would you rather than do would you
rather than do Dunkin egg or would you
rather than do Targaryen Civil War or do
you want to see something else as of
right now George our Martin has an
option to do a prequel series as far as
I know there hasn't been any development
along those lines but he said like after
the second episode they started
discussing prequel series like literally
after the second episode george RR
martin had a lunch with one of the top
people at HBO and he was like we want 10
years of Game of Thrones and George are
Martin's like that sounds great I would
love that
so most likely scenario 7 seasons in the
main show and then a prequel series
would start you know around you know the
time Season 6 or season 7 starts if they
were gonna start a spin-off series and
they wanted to get it out by the start
of like season 6 or sometime you know
around 2016 they'd really have to get
going fast so I think it's more likely
that it would start around season 7 if
they were actively developing a spin-off
right now which I don't think that they
are I think they already would have
announced some stuff as of right now
they're just worrying about the main
show my next bonus videos is probably to
be like a Daenerys like a straight-up
Daenerys video for season 5 so be sure
to subscribe to get that I might get
that up by Sunday at least by next week
if you guys really want I'll do a deeper
video on Duncan egg there's just like
there's so much material that is really
interesting
speaking of which congrats to this
week's giveaway winner bidis you win a
copy of the season 4 DVD be sure to
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info for those
that are asking about the HBO streaming
service
HBO now we have some more information
about that what's going to happen is is
it's exclusive to Apple meaning that you
have to have a US App Store account or
iTunes account but it's essentially the
same thing that doesn't mean you have to
live in the u.s. to use it it just means
you need to be able to buy things
through the United States Apple Store on
a mobile device
people in international countries there
are a couple workarounds to do this so
you can still use HBO now but you have
to buy the HBO now service through the
App Store and it has to be the u.s. app
store I know that sounds a little bit
weird but like sky and other
international broadcasters have
exclusive digital rights to Game of
Thrones in country so like if you don't
have HBO now in your country it's
because your broadcaster doesn't want
you to have it not because HBO doesn't
want you to have it so don't yell at HBO
personally if you are in a foreign
country and you really want HBO now I
just recommend that you try the
workaround starting at the beginning of
April I'm still going to be giving away
subscriptions if you are in an
international country it'll probably
just be PayPal so you can you can try
and find a workaround if you want so you
can still win giveaways in an
international country so don't worry
about that so why you guys wait for that
Daenerys video you can click here for my
breakdown to the second trailer way
cooler than the first trailer in you can
click here for my breakdown or my
synopsis of the first three episodes
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight now let's all do the
thing
you